The sight of a pointed dorsal fin peeking
out above the water immediately evokes our
fight or flight response, but should sharks
really cause humans so much anxiety? Or did we
sensationalize and demonize a fish into a monster?
Not to mention those people who have a general
phobia of the ocean, thalassophobia.
The inability to see what is below,
a fear of drowning, of darkness, of the
unknown — these fears helped create a lot
of sea monsters, both real and imagined.
Throw in a carnivorous fish and it's easy
to make a real animal a monster—and a lot of
people have capitalized on that with the shark.
Yet despite the rarity of shark attacks on
humans, these animals have an unwarranted
reputation as blood-thirsty maneaters. And you
can largely thank horror movies for the bad PR.
So if sharks are not naturally aggressive
towards humans, why did we turn a fish that
kills fewer people a year than falling
coconuts and bee stings into such an iconic killer?
The idea of the shark as a monster is
certainly linked to their powerful jaws,
muscular bodies, and celebrated olfactory
abilities—not to mention those teeth.
Ifind a lot of sharks cute, but even I don’t
want to see those pearly whites up close.
They are powerful creatures that remind humans we
are not the animals at the top of the food chain.
Perhaps fear of sharks is simply a
lingering biological response to the
possibility of being eaten
by these capable hunters.
Still, sharks don’t hunt and eat humans, unlike
some lions and other big cats, bears, or hell,
even pythons. Yet they frequently terrorize
us on the big screen and in newspapers alike.
There are a few shark-type monsters in mythology
and folklore, like the Japanese yokai Isonade,
the Classical Greek monster Scylla with its
many heads and three rows of shark-like teeth,
or the primordial sea monster Cipactli from
Mesoamerican mythology, but there are
far more shark deities — although some like the
Hawaiian Nanaue could fall into either category.
The Polynesian peoples both feared
and revered sharks. In some stories,
there are monstrous sharks that eat people, but
there are also stories of sharks possessed by
ancestral spirits rescuing humans. According to
other legends, some chiefs kept pet sharks who
recognized members of the family.
In Africa along the west coast,
some cultures included shark meat as part of
their diet, while others saw them as sacred.
Either way, they learned how to live alongside
the shark since respect was paramount.
We start to see sharks in a more
predominantly negative light from
European sources around the 16th century.
In 1553 Spanish historian Francisco López
de Gómara recounted Spanish conquistador
Hernán Cortés’s conquest of Mexico.
which included the conqueror's
interaction with sharks,
describing them as “insatiable”
and capable of swallowing anything.
While further describing sharks, it is written
that they will “attack a cow or horse grazing or
drinking at the river’s edge and will eat a man.”
Slave-trade sailors heard of the xoc from the Maya
of the Caribbean and turned the word
to ‘sharke’ around the 16th century.
Written historical records from slave ships
mention sharks, along with other fish, swimming
alongside the boats, eager to eat whatever
was thrown overboard—from excrement to people.
In the 18th century, abolitionists used
violent imagery of sharks eating Africans
thrown overboard from slave ships to further
emphasize the horrors of the slave trade.
Artists immortalized these haunting images.
More visual depictions of shark encounters
appeared after a cabin boy named Brook Watson fell
overboard and had his leg bitten off by a shark in
Havana, Cuba. The incident became the inspiration
for a famous painting: Watson and the Shark.
Then in the mid-19th century,
human-shark encounters became
a more popular fixture on the global news
circuit when the Birkenhead Steamer sank.
Newspapers reported that hundreds of sharks
occupying the surrounding reefs laid “devastation”
to the survivors. According to survivor Benjamin
Turner, who was a child at the time of the wreck,
“A shark would come up, seize them by the leg, and
drag them down.” These vivid testimonies, and the
accompanying images, led to one of the first media
representations of a so-called “feeding frenzy.”
Still, sharks were considered relatively
harmless until the 20th century.
A series of human-shark encounters
in New Jersey in 1916 led to major
newspapers labeling the animals as so-called
“man-eating monsters,” causing a wave of panic.
Around the same time on the other
side of the world in Australia,
surfing was gaining popularity. As more
humans entered into shark habitats, the
news began to pay attention to fatal encounters.
Public and political outcry led to the “meshing”
of metropolitan beaches; nets were installed along
the coastline to catch sharks that got too close.
In 1958, The Shark Attack File was founded
to document global shark encounters.
Overwhelmingly, however, sharks were still at the
periphery of consciousness for most. Until Jaws.
The famous film is based on a
1974 novel of the same name,
inspired in part by those 1916 New Jersey events.
When the film adaptation hit theaters in 1975
it was accompanied by massive fanfare.
Jaws defined the summer blockbuster.
It helped launch Steven Spielberg’s career,
gave us one of the most iconic movie scores
of all time, and made a whole lot of
people terrified to go into the water.
We can partially thank Universal Studios'marketing team for that. Inspiring fear seemed to be their driving strategy.
"It is as if God created the devil . . ."
". . . and gave him . . . Jaws."
Teasers of the film ran on TV (to the tune of
$700,000 dollars) and merchandise with the iconic
film poster was created. The fact that people
didn’t have much knowledge about sharks made it
easy for the media to exploit fear of the unknown.
That fear taps into not just being prey but how
you might become prey— in other words, the
jaws of Jaws is what really freaks us out.
Jaws also plays on fears (and guilt) of war,
comments on mass hysteria, and criticizes the
reckless scientist. Comparisons of the film’s
mayor to the disgraced President Richard Nixon
indicate parallels between the shark-coverup
and Watergate. And then there’s the Freudian
reading of a giant male predator engaging in a
little voyeurism before attacking a naked woman,
but there’s also the feminist reading that sees
the shark as a metaphor of the monstrous feminine
and/or the folkloric myth of vagina dentata.
Regardless of how you interpret the film,
it's indisputable that the Great White Shark
at its center is meant to be the monster.
"You're gonna need a bigger boat."
A lot went wrong during the filming of Jaws,
including rough ocean waters, bad weather,
and the mechanical shark’s frequent malfunctions.
Nicknamed Bruce after Spielberg’s lawyer,
the animatronic shark used in the film was
notoriously finicky. The exposure to saltwater
in Martha’s Vineyard led to the mechanic’s
erosion—and even greater unpredictability.
But these turned out to be what Bob Ross might
call “happy little accidents.” The inability
to show the metal puppet on screen contributed
to its mysterious menace; we don’t see the full
shark until more than halfway through the movie.
In some ways, Jaws feels like an extension of
the kaiju and “big bug” film genres, with
a little more horror and action thrown in
alongside Hitchcockian thriller for good measure.
It’s man vs. nature with a slasher flick twist.
Post Jaws, sharks were handed the dubious title
of “monsters of the deep.” It probably didn’t
help that Jaws author Peter Benchley knew very
little about sharks. And most people took the
film’s portrayal of a fictional shark monster as
the normal behavior of real Great White Sharks.
Immediately after the film’s
release, beachgoers headed inland,
damaging coastal town economies. Shark fishing
competitions became a thing. Despite the panic,
and the damage to sharks the movie caused, it also
inspired future scientists and the public to learn
more about sharks in general. Benchley by the
way? He became a vocal shark conservationist.
Jaws solidified and popularized the
perspective of sharks as monsters
and ushered in the “sharksploitation” genre.
As digital special effects emerged in the 1990s,
monster shark films became even more
popular…we can’t seem to get enough.
As special effects improved,
films began to make the shark
even scarier—by making them bigger. Much bigger.
Enter the megalodon. The idea of the prehistoric
fish surviving extinction was introduced in
the Jaws book, when Hooper, an oceanographer,
speculates that the titular massive white shark
is likely a smaller version of a creature lurking
far deeper down in the ocean. He mentions
megalodons and questions if they are extinct.
In 1997, another author would pick up
on that thread and expand it—literally.
Meg: A Novel of Deep Terror by Steve Altenfollows a scientist diving the Mariana Trenchon behalf of the US Navy
who sees a megalodon and spends the rest
of his Captain Ahab-esq life trying to
prove it exists. The book opens with an awesome
scene of a T-Rex getting eaten by a megalodon.
Unfortunately, the Meg books’ film adaptation
in 2018 didn’t include that scene.
But it did give us Jason Statham underwater
fighting a fairly impressive CGI shark.
While in the past the media
latched on to the sensational.
With The Meg we got the requisite monster
shark attention but with a side of science.
"Mac, tracker is live!"
"Great, real him in, DJ."
The overwhelming majority of scientists
insist the megalodon is indeed extinct,
for millions of years, in fact, not hiding in
the modern depths of the Mariana Trench.
Plus,the movie shark version is chunkier, longer, and
tolerates cold water better than the real thing.
As for its resemblance to a
great white shark?
Evidence suggests megalodons were more
closely related to mako sharks.
These pop culture shark monsters still
have an impact on the real world.
Scholars and scientists have proven that
negative portrayals of sharks in the media,
fictional or otherwise, directly correlate
to how people conceptualize the real deal.
Even reputable networks like the Discovery
Channel capitalize on the shark-monster phenomenon
with faux megalodon documentaries or “serial
killer” shark mysteries. These fictionalized
shows rely not only on campy entertainment value
but on humanity’s appetite for positioning natural
species as supernatural monsters. The fish becomes
a serial killer, a spectral figure—a monster.
Many sharks today are facing the
threat of extinction—primarily
because of human actions. Threats to shark
populations include fishing, fin harvesting,
pollution, habitat loss, and climate change.
It is estimated that 100 million sharks are killed
every year for commercial
profit. As apex predators,
the removal of sharks from the food chain has
a catastrophic effect on marine ecosystems.
Today, some scuba divers seek out shark
encounters, looking not for monsters but for
beauties, honoring the animals by respecting
them and studying them—not demonizing them.
Sharks aren’t devious, man-hunting
killers. We made them monsters.